yeah man where's this episode 4 we're
back baby gasps II obviously remember
hold on I know I see them but remember
episode 1 while you're talking about
blow jobs and head and [ __ ] load up yeah
when you were talking about you were
listed yeah obviously the feedback from
that was a lot of people were thinking a
lot of people laughing i when when they
saw me and I was talking to you about it
but I started to then think about what
if couples were watching it together and
then the girl looks at the guy does the
guy like I do I give do I give [ __ ]
head or do I give just no do I suck a
dick do I suck your dick or do I give
you I give my head yeah I give you head
of course of controversy I was in like
Little Liars we all know we all know she
don't give you good hurt mmm there's
only certain amaya goals in this world
that give great head hmm
some girls give ok head some girls can't
give head it's not their fault as well
like perhaps to be fair the feedback
that I got from that exact thing
yeah was also that a lot of girls simply
don't like giving head and that
perplexes me you know why why would you
want to please Broadway but this is the
thing that I this is the thing that I
fought by it yeah was when I got that
when I but I when I got that feedback
yeah
I was like do they not like giving head
what are they not like given their man
head because it wasn't because like I
like I'll eat us right oh I'll do all
sorts but I'm not gonna eat anyone's ha
ha I didn't want to comment too soon to
say I'm already anyone's ass [ __ ]
agreed I don't have to be it's like some
more of Oh like what you're willing to
do yeah it's not even not willing but
what you're happy to do
is more about like the vibe that you get
yeah and there's obviously people like
that's something that I learn later on
where I've actually been in
relationships with people and then like
as a crew we would be talking like ah
Ian's ass doing this and I belong yuck
you know hey you know back in the day
you must be my Eno mizar's but really I
just wasn't about it with yeah oh yeah
yeah but yeah with that person yeah
agreed
and then obviously you have a few more
experiences you find a couple people
like Bravo your ass or so I've never
sucked at oppa I love is either certain
people that are probably woods so when
it comes to the dick sucking thing yeah
I know you love it was an indirect buff
I gave the opportunity to react to react
on what you doing the confines of your
bedroom is your business for just just
for context about the sucking tasting
I've sucked one girl's toe before and it
was a big one as well and probably was I
think it was a big I can't remember yeah
this was this was way before he was I
have an N thing or a ting or whatever
and I told the man them and they just
burst out laughing at me so almost you
know they say it was but yes this was
years ago that was years ago I maybe 10
ml that was once a [ __ ] in now fam but
these times to be fair like obviously
when you told me I was out what's wrong
with you but now the more and what you
see different type of women you're lying
order you see like I can understand if
you were caught up in in the moment yeah
yeah yeah
I was caught up in a moment like I knew
it was saying she liked and me
personally I'm a pleaser and if I'm feed
if I've got the vibe as well like if and
I was dating the girl at the time it
wasn't just a one-time thing so if I'm
feeling the go and if I know she likes
something nine times out of ten I'm more
than happy to try and because I'm I'm
more than pleased alike I get pleasure
from pleasing girls wanna sex with them
as opposed to just [ __ ] them for my
benefit yeah most girls well not most
girls but obviously guys [ __ ] girls just
a bus or not sometimes but depending on
your rags same here I
it turns me on to be a pleaser man it
turns me on it turns me on that I turn
them on yeah that's nice yeah but um so
yeah that's the thing I was referring to
with them when I got the feedback are
they don't know sucking dick yeah I'm
just like maybe they just haven't found
the person that they're that truly about
it yeah they're truly like you suck your
dick because if you like I was saying
this to someone the other day and then
like they're always people like you say
when I say would you like would you like
not would you rather but necessarily
like what would you do like if you see
like a supermodel or something and I'll
send it to you now what would you give
to [ __ ] over you and sucking a toe would
be the first thing I would do my easiest
thing I've that's the thing and
obviously I know there's there's girls
that I've seen where I've heard pheeba
that are they don't I sucking dick or
whatever yeah but if I show them the
right guy and say would you suck his
dick there's swallow it whole don't you
have one of them ones yeah dumb ones but
it's like is cool for that so maybe they
just not about it yeah with that guy
yeah with that guy all them all previous
guys that they stopped off because I I
refuse to believe that girls don't like
sucking dick or guys don't like Ian are
vagina I refuse to believe that because
it's not like you're gonna find out one
person that you've got I know you got I
don't want to wake up in the morning to
a vagina in my face no you can happy it
never do I'll punch you yeah in that
moment in time no I don't like eating
vagina that's just a hideous experience
but when you find the for the right
person I remember the first time I went
down on a girl the first ever time you
say yours anyway I wrote the first that
she did [ __ ] believe she didn't
believe I was a newbie I was gassed bro
she knew I was a newbie that's back when
you had that age and that time in your
life was not cool yeah to be honest yeah
and if someone asked you like not yeah
yeah yeah someone asks you like I've got
a point about that and someone asked you
you know
let me take away man does his Chinese
[ __ ] me gross oh yeah so both like dem
ones the first ever time was around
their era when it's not cool to be in
vaginas yeah so I remember when she
asked me to do it and I was good and I
went down there to do it I think so I
didn't offer okay cuz I wasn't about it
yeah mix it and I was just there like I
made sure my nose is on top of the thing
so I didn't want to get any fragrances
not back there was anything to smell
anyway but maybe because he was away and
I was just there like just a precaution
yeah yeah I didn't know nothing about
clear I didn't know about anything like
Bravo just that I didn't want to swallow
nothing I didn't want anything so just
but yeah obviously I don't want to wake
up eat your vagina first no one else
he's all about the situation that you're
in
mm-hmm and it's not about yeah it's all
about this like yeah there's days when
you're like even if you're with someone
like oh you've got partner or whatever
yeah and you don't want to go down them
everything to be a chore in it yeah you
just want to get a lost you just want to
get lost some day you'll go down there
sometimes you might find yourself Ian
are sometimes you're just at you're
sucking titty sometimes she's gonna suck
you up sometimes like all sorts proud
yeah so it's all about a situation that
you're in so yeah I I refuse to believe
that there's such a large population of
women that just did have disdain for
sucking penis it's just it you just not
about it yeah that person yeah for that
person hundred percent you just haven't
get got lost in it yet yeah but yeah
that's what I have to say about that
yeah well the first time I did it I
can't remember like where I wasn't all
of that remember the girl was with
because she was my girlfriend at the
time this was going on maybe ten years
ago don't know where it was but I did it
we had sex everything and it felt
natural to me doing it I felt like I
knew it never done it before but I felt
like I knew I was doing yeah that makes
sense and then after all was said and
done she asked me oh no I think she
asked me prior
what I said no and then she ever
messaged me or told me straight after
like your ally you've done it before
it's like now actually have it's the
first time okay from that one from that
day no notion yours and yours gonna do
yeah we're a school from I I learned I
was good about why I knew I was good II
when I actually found the time I wanted
to do it yeah yeah yeah that's when I
caught was a bat and that's when like it
felt normal natural cuz I actually
wanted to do it and yeah yeah it wasn't
the case or anyone asked me to do it or
I thought I was obligated to do it or
just yeah that's what I want to say here
one of the first times I ever met you
yeah yeah it's about ten years ago now
as well it was me you and Aaron who was
sat in [ __ ] what's that place cool we
used to study yeah no no no no not
coffee Union but we went to the other
place Henley College yeah yeah Henley we
were all sat there he's probably the
third or fourth time I've ever senior
was in like that was social and whoever
was all just talking get to know each
other and either either he or I know it
was Aaron Aaron was like undercover just
like you know you man you may never even
never they like he [ __ ] then I was like
I didn't want to say yeah I remember is
one of the first times I've ever met you
yeah I was like and then you jumped in
strain you were like yeah Rex straight
face you're like yeah Rex I remember I
was a kid me and him lose each other
life rough you can't just go run if you
want to be our friend you gotta be busy
and you know what Thanks
of course I do you'll do but don't don't
say serve blase it was such taboo fam it
was funny
taboos that's funny bro it was weird
that oh my god
no it's I honestly don't remember that
in a slightest in the slightest these
times I'm like on I was a child whoever
let me live by myself and have sex by
myself where I was
I wasn't old enough I actually want to
talk about iron today for this one
heartbreak home I just took [ __ ] oh boy
that's tough mum I talked to me so like
I didn't even know I didn't even have
like a question answer format to be fair
I just wanted to talk about heartbreak
because I feel like in our little
section mmm
there's like three of us in particular
now little squad this free of us that
were just where our hearts on a sleeve
really [ __ ] cards they have come from
squashed it and I just feel it needs to
be addressed I just what it's time to be
vulnerable for a little bit know what
like hop right man dem have emotions you
know I feel like you're thinking that we
don't have emotions or girl like I'm
told many a time that I'm heartless but
you've told me I'm heartless you can be
I can't be but when I'm in love like
I've been in love once in my life
and it's it's hard to [ __ ] like be it
for me being in love or loving someone
not not that was one Benelux I feel like
the two different things yeah being in
love is loving that person more do you
love yourself that's the way I view it
and that's the way I've valued that
person I that period of time when I was
with her Jesus Christ
yeah I like a poor on a pedestal and
like everything everyone wants to do was
just so like benefit asked menifee her
that was the way I thought that was the
way I thought I obviously didn't work
out Brett deter but a heartbreak
situation is it's hard to overcome
because you feel you honestly feel like
you've lost something like from yourself
and then but what's what's mad is forget
obviously girls show a lot more than
guys in terms of they can see in their
face you can see you in their body
language you can see you know whereas
guys on a day-to-day basis we just try
our best to go out go our day by day
life on holiday by day routine and what
a guy's mentality is that we need to
bounce back so the first thing guys tend
to do is try and [ __ ] someone else to
get over it
y'see the reason why we do that is
because we just need that clarity or
need that you know release all that
relief
just doing it whereas if a girl was to
know that a guy did that after just
breaking up or being broken up with deal
with thing oh you just wanted to fight
anyway they're happy that they then
broke up with you exactly we just need
that's it not we but like the majority
I'm hundred centimeter on the majority
of guys just needs that sense of relief
because there's no other way of closure
per se because obviously is not closure
with the girl that you were with but we
just need that you know what yeah yeah
again yeah yeah and you just need their
confirmation that like obviously someone
can break up with you I think obviously
goes Moscow finishes well but obviously
some could break up with you and you're
just like you're looking at a critical
version of yourself yeah and then
sleeping with someone else after that
gives me a little bit of confirmation
that like maybe it's not me yeah maybe
it's not maybe I'm not the most
undesirable pretty not necessarily it's
not them but it's not just yeah it's not
just me with the issue that they I just
like want to move on yeah and it never
[ __ ] works yeah but it's a little
something in it mmm and is yeah it gives
you a little almost like a little
distraction for the time as well yeah
and that's all that's all guys needs to
be fair at that period in time a
distraction hmm but girls they're more
than happy to just like what are we know
in filth they relish in it I don't and I
don't and they go for like a serious
grieving process they have four stages
they literally do mmm it's mad right and
it's the time where they're happy and
they're done is when we're sad because
once what we've realized after you've
had was like after we broken up had sex
other people blah blah you slow science
go over it and you go through that phase
where you start to reminisce so you
start seeing old sex message really see
or an Instagram or whatever he starts
finger-fuck actually like this girl even
if I broke up with her I she broke up me
regardless do not mean and it's like
when they're moved on or like happy and
closure but the growth and stuff mandem
start to feel a certain type of way yeah
yeah like 30 I've said you all time
everyone's to be wanted so the time you
do see her move on whatever you're like
[ __ ] she doesn't want me anymore then
you try to put in that I've seen in me
mod I see the meme on Instagram
there times when your ex finding funds
closure and you pop up and say hi how
are you doing whatever kind of things
there and it's it's funny way so true
the matter people that do dinosaur this
soldier Abram I don't know if I've ever
done that per se but it's it's just true
like I can understand why people do it
Brice I don't even know man it's just
like I I'm a weird one as well yeah cuz
I don't know I don't know that I've ever
gone through
gen I don't know if I've ever gone
through what you've gone what anyone
heartbreak genuine heartbreak
I've had about nine or ten mini heart
breaks
a mini heart breaks by wallowed I didn't
want to eat I didn't want to sleep I
never see there's that one in particular
we're talking about innit bruv
she called man a frog she said I was
ugly I shoulda listened to my friends
[Laughter]
so yeah the story of this one said there
was a girl [ __ ] hey does ago she was
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] crazy and I had no
business doing anything with her but she
was beautiful undeniably beautiful we
had a thing we were happy everything was
blessed and then she will just randomly
cut me off
mm-hm and I think in essence when I like
in retrospect rather than when I look
back it I think it was more of a case of
I only wired her because she didn't want
me yeah yeah I know you mean and I think
in terms of like literally all the mini
heartbreaks I've had yeah I've only ever
wanted them because they didn't want me
okay and her especially because she
would just she was nuts but I didn't
know she was nothing was mucking crazy
she would just come out she would just
flog me off every couple of months for
no reason yeah and say it was me um and
I think that's why I was so obsessed of
her yeah
I mean the time when she genuinely
locked it
delete my number every failure of it I
was in my room I was youtubing I'd never
listens approach in my life I was
youtubing bird true I so moist
you're so moist I was vulnerable then oh
[ __ ] you too big boy and then I was
about what seven eight years ago it was
years ago and then and then yeah I was I
was [ __ ] and then yeah I didn't know
what to do and I think back here now and
then like I was always how do I say it I
was always more depressed yeah when I
was always more depressed when she
didn't want me then I was happy when she
wanted me does that make sense
you were more depressed I was more
depressed yeah when she didn't want me
yeah
then I was happy when she did want me oh
she does that make sense yeah so when we
were good yeah I was cool when she
didn't want me I was there like suicidal
and I don't know what it is I feel like
that's every woman I've ever been with
that like we're like heartbreak whatever
I've had he's purely been down to them
just not wanting me I mean what in them
more because they didn't want me yeah
everyone was to be wanted everyone was
to be wanted yeah I'm like I don't know
proof it was a weird one yeah yeah then
again I've never gone free what you
going free bomb I can't even talk about
weapons heartbreak is robot for mundum
like unless if you've not been in love
then obviously doesn't count but I've
been in love once and vulnerability is
key moonlights not key but it's it's
hard thing to deal with everyone's
everyone's what about any given point
heartbreak
it hurts ma'am it does hurt but you
gotta move one man you gotta move one
you got them don't put its name of last
name good [ __ ] topes yeah this sounds
terrible you're gonna laugh I'm pretty
short terms as a cut do you know what
cluck is
yes Toad's loves the hurt of love so
much he loves the drama heartbroken he
literally lists for it he boy he just
needs to sit there and wallow in it he
needs to be in pain to be happy and I
wouldn't be surprised if when he is like
a little bit older and he's married and
everything's stable and settles down I
wouldn't be surprised if we found out
that he pays guys to come over and [ __ ]
his wife in front of him so you can sit
there in the corner you [ __ ] how
could you do this to me
that would turn him on I remember the
time he broke up our heap no I think
he's go at the time break up with him
and he people on his since he was out
any point his Instagram or no regrets
he's going for a wild night never gets I
like that and I open it's a gravity
story he's like I lied mad regretted
drowned his sorrows and he drowned
himself oh he's funny he's funny he
lives for the pain there's certain
people like he must listen to like the
weekend all the time or something bro
Drake the weekend all of it all of them
driving driving around in midnight just
thinking about killing loves to
romanticize the pain of a relationship
it's crazy it's funny he is funny though
funny I'll never I would never forget
that no regretting bringing up to me all
the time it's why need oh Christ
but yeah man I don't know what it is I
don't know what it is
boy ladies if you listening just be nice
man novelty guys man just love us we
just want to be wanted everyone wants to
be one everyone wants to be wanted and
that I'm not even gonna delve back into
it mmm but when we were referring to the
cheating thing before yeah
when we last sat down I
I've had occasions in that like this is
actually to be fair
ignore the chief he has nothing to do
with Chi and I've definitely had
occasions in where I would be happier
like you know mean you just out and
you're like brother I'm pulling and
pulling on it yeah I need to pull I need
to know I need to do this I need to do
that yeah you go out a go cracks on you
have a nice conversation she's down and
you're like I'm wanted yeah I am want
right now yes God doesn't even know me
yeah yeah yeah she wants it like he's
that to me is more satisfying than the
the whole end product yeah because then
if you end up [ __ ] her it's even
going to her house the process of the
process diving there we've got kind of
whatever we focus I've got a sleep there
or I have to come all the way back and
then it just feel like [ __ ] if I am
sleeping there I gotta do the walk of
shame the next day it's just a whole
[ __ ] hassle if she comes to yours
you've gotta find a way to get her out
and is she allowed to stay she know he's
just long the whole kind of the whole
romance of like me and someone walk in
you're attracted they're attracted the
chase that the same detention a thrill
and then it all comes to a head and then
you you know she's down yeah and she
might invite you you might know the
opportunities there too if I heard from
me if I could just cut that don't go
through the rest and I'm just like gasps
yes in a moment yeah I see sexual
tension the tension the tension the
traces where it's at if it's easy it's
pointless if it's easy actually point
was that message I sent you the other
day get you what you just said there
under some pack lyric oh yeah yeah yeah
I don't remember I remember you sending
it he fun no I can get it than I've
already had it I'm cool brav if I know I
can get it then I've already had it the
chase for chase we're so but don't make
me chase to you if any was this is an
epic it now I'm gonna make I'm given up
too easy
they need to be chasing no don't there's
a difference between a chase and a
marathon some girls like to be marathons
and I'm not [ __ ] about it prov know
about I'm not about no no realtor I'm
about like a little flirty chase a nice
playful flirty chase that lasts less
than an hour I'm game
this thing that last weeks and months is
she interested is she not interested am
I wasting my time that's not a chase
yeah that's a mindfuck there is a
mindfuck and I hate you like do you not
want to get satisfied like do you do you
just want to cream yourself and not even
actually get [ __ ] but that's the
point
what's the pledget I mean what's the
point what is the point of gassing me
for so long what's the point gas me for
weeks or months just fast not to
probably meet up
it's pointless I hate I hate stuff but
girls are happily to do and I don't get
it mmm and the maddest thing is that
girls are hornier than guys and that's a
fact
but girls could control themselves guys
car it doesn't make sense to me from
girls 100% avoid in guys 100% but yours
have to act like girls how do you how do
you know that they don't even ice it's
just they are anyone who says noise a
lie off the difference is guys are
upfront guys will happily talk about sex
cows would be like I'll [ __ ] this girl
[ __ ] they go blah blah and ghazal I
haven't looked down and abandon my Fiat
but the thing is girls not necessarily
would [ __ ] bare guys but if they found a
guy do you wanna [ __ ] they're more than
happy to talk crud do crud
so when I say girls are more hornier
than guys I'm gonna [ __ ] guys one of the
guys one of what girls it's a fact but
the difference with guys these guys
would more will be happy to [ __ ] a 2ri
10 or a 7 out of 10 3 days a week
whereas a girl would [ __ ] a guy that's a
9 eternal in their opinion every day of
the week because they know that's their
man and they're yeah yeah yeah Matt on
on top of what you're saying
they're absolutely ruining I've always
found that goes can go like if a girl
hasn't had sex in time months she's cool
she's cool why should she go she could
show years go it doesn't matter I'm
shaking
mumps I'm shaking whoa girls like it is
crazy like if they can go you mumps and
years without dick and not give a [ __ ]
and as soon as they get [ __ ] one one
good time that's
they're ravenous animals you're right
they will [ __ ] all day every day they
want it but yeah guys complete opposite
the longer it is the more red I see yeah
and then once I'm [ __ ] tomorrow
tomorrow I get it I go another two
months I'm nice I just want to feel
warmth that's literally what we need one
warmth and safety mmm this is a new
poster good new [ __ ] good but a home
piece to make you feel safe fun and
that's facts it's true as facts it is
true both for home [ __ ] Oh different
kind of [ __ ] mmm them ones where you
know that once you bustin up you can
still snuggle and you're calm with it
there's loads of girls that [ __ ] in my
past and I just want to leave or I just
want them to it's like ah because oh
it's mad it's mad going back to episode
one hard dick makes you do madness is
madness is and it drives it drives me
insane because there must be a chemical
imbalance hmm because as soon as I'm not
I'm like what was I thinking not
necessarily about the girl that [ __ ]
messaging this person that you know I
mean I'm just like what was I think I
really need that nut bro I start
contemplating a question myself it
tampers with your neurology it doesn't
make sense doesn't make sense it doesn't
make sense
I can't stand it I literally can't stand
it but I've done ridiculous things when
I morning ridiculous outrageous things
and you're right as soon as you're not
you just so what was I thinking what was
the point of this it's crazy and it's
not for every girl obviously like I said
if you found a real one like new person
you busy at home in a little while if
you find a right if you've had a real
one and you bust an eye on your your
children you're happy you know you know
what the beauty of harm [ __ ] is hmm
good good sex good good nut mmm roll
over little spoon let me be little spoon
you know me I love a little spoon I love
being spooned oh you already know
there's one there's one girl there's one
girl in particular we used to [ __ ] this
was time ago a year and a half ago
he's the [ __ ] every time we fight she
knew I love being spooned she's small as
well she's about five four or five watts
so we should spoon me and I would Kip oh
yeah
it just felt cozy brav coat like I
missed it baby spoon oh I'll be small
split any day let me be from any day oh
good especially when I took is small it
just feel I don't know what about other
ways I just mean it's the battle
comfortable Oh [ __ ] out oh my god
small spoon is underrated it's the only
way to go underrated mind I'm not do big
spoon not the povo flip over to let us
be newfound trust me you know I hate
about being baby spoon is that like
because it's such a a yachty feminine
position fetal position thing yeah brah
you have to be comfortable in a
relationship before you can perman it
Nathan because when you're but when
you're comfy comfy you can be as
feminine as you want with it like you're
their backs art you'll go your back is
art she's stroking your head back
history yeah he could've shaken of head
fam oh my gosh I was out on what's today
what's today Sunday on Wednesday all my
friends birthdays when they went around
town or whatever and justice girl she's
probably watching so she she knows who
she is anyway she saw me said hello blah
blah meet-and-greet well not me in grano
before saying hello headset and he
started stroking my head like this of
all of a sudden I was like I was in
euphoria and I said to her this is like
this is my sweet spot like it's like my
g-spot I don't think maybe you'd add to
me your I'm yours like I'm a temp ie I'm
putting my and your hand and it's like I
just feel tired I feel vulnerable I feel
close to you I feel everything and I
just I just felt safe I felt cool and I
said to her you you have to stop doing
it cuz that is Maui's why she did it one
more time I was like ah Braves stop
and on head this leap I'm going to lino
and I always works me when I'm most like
at my weakest point when you're hanging
probably but bro I was about you just
finished my sentence I know when I'm
hung the [ __ ] over no no I need I need a
good woman to [ __ ] me I don't even want
I want to lay there get [ __ ] like I'm
a [ __ ]
roll over get little spooned fingers in
my elm on my hair on my head I'm happy
I'm going I'm having the best sleep I
can possibly have hip in you've done a
good job thank you thank you
tomorrow you want to be a real woman do
that those are the quality of man's
hanging [ __ ] good roll them over spoon
is clot and run your fingers through his
hair that's what he's yours
ah you don't ask so much you know that's
what I want I don't want anything else
but that we don't ask for much it's much
lit you all I want it's party nuts
that's not good good Jesus Christ
she what I know so funny always Oh not
funny but like I don't even have to
describe it
so scenario so let's say you've been
talking to a girl for ages ages ages
they say age for like a week the sexual
tension is there that there all day you
know you're gonna bang her
yeah when you're gonna bang on and I
still use it ages invented a week that's
funny
go on a week is a long time thought
someone that's a long time two days go
sometime yeah or the same yeah you're
talking that you know you're gonna bang
her she knows you're gonna bang you you
don't know when though so the time now
comes you go to the yard or she comes to
your yard and you're doing the whole the
introduction obligatory sitting on a
safe are chillin watching TV breaking
attention rare tear tear it plays out
two ways let's say you both go to the
room back each others clothes off you
start banging and it's calm like no one
even thinks about condoms no one even
thinks about like protection or blah
blah who if I fought two of you five
blow up you just you just crack on but
then you think about afterwards what
more time to go with think about more
than a guy because the guys just pass on
irony let's go to bed but the girl
thinks about afterwards but let's say
you've been talking to a girl for
week wherever wherever you go to where
yard but you've not mentioned the fact
that you guys gonna have sex you both
know you're gonna have sex but it's not
been verbalized hmm you go to the room
and then you pull out a condom
awkward awkward do you know why it's
awkward because in their head they now
think you've only come in for sex even
though the whole week you've been
talking crud the whole week even telling
me you're gonna suck my dick
I've been said I'm gonna eat you out
I'll pull up once I pull out the condom
the condom rather it's it's verbalized
oh it's affirmative that we are [ __ ]
well you're gonna get mad at that yeah
but if I just slipped in without a Dom
you're in your for you don't care but
it's almost like a condom it's a mistake
it's very true Wow I mean that's a
that's an interesting thing it's as soon
as you pull it out as long as it's not
because he's not been verbalize before
and as soon as you pull out John you
think the girl think wow you're an
actual [ __ ] yeah you've come here
just the bus or not even though we both
know it was gonna happen anyway right
that's true
and no one's and if I didn't pull it out
and no one's our Nast's aren't you
forgot kind of you've not asked me of a
girl condom and we just fight and you're
happy with that but as soon as I've got
to protect myself you're not have to
protect you ooh I mean all of a sudden
is a problem all of a sudden it's a
problem but is this sighting that makes
them switch I'm not even talking about
it from experience I'm talking about
because I feel like it happens and a
formality of a condom it's like it's not
you have to stop you have to break that
you have to stop everything what you're
doing the lips in the whatever you're
doing you have to stop rip the teamplay
on it's just like okay give them time to
think yeah how can you do it is whatever
you like you hear is it it's um yeah
it's the formality of it it's like if
you I don't know if you enter a strip
club
yeah and then luckily that's probably
why they do it you pay before when you
get a dance in it yeah but imagine if
you pay it after it kills everything it
was every because area yeah yeah yeah
and just there you're in emotions there
yeah you're horny you're convinced that
she's horny you're convinced she was
like once you like she wants you but
she's just not allowed it that's what
she tells you yeah I'd love to [ __ ] you
but like don't know what the rules are
the rules
there's all that madness yeah yeah yeah
and then you walk out you feel fine you
just like rough that was sick let's go
have a good night whereas if you pay it
after you go there all of this has
happened this is happening great great
great great great she's out I want to
[ __ ] you but my mind at the doorman let
a happen oh you're so this this this and
this and then she's like all that would
be they'll be very quick that'd be very
good for you could hundred that's just
ruin the whole that's ruin the day for
me ruined everything because you've just
realized that so just the formality and
that's the same as the condom thing yeah
it's like we were caught up in this you
want me I want you with this this and
this and then you pull out the condom
and it's like this is the mechanics oh
my that's the mechanics of it that's
disgusting
yes why I never wear a condom brother
[Applause]
always we're laughing because we know
it's not a joke oh my god
that's funny now I'm playing but it's
funny but I'm playing I'm not [ __ ] yeah
no one's playing well condoms are long
you see the [ __ ] waste condoms anyway
the thing is like I've been good
recently like I said to Bella Jesus
because she knows everything I do and if
you don't remember from the first
episode Bella's my flatmate I lived with
a female I tell everything she knows
everything and I tell her for me I do
blah blah cause we're cool
and I said so I'll recently I've been
strapping up like I've been you know
being good strapping up everything while
I'm [ __ ] I should all good cuz prize
that I lost my virginity without a
condom so I've always felt way it's like
without a condom yeah yeah I remember
the first time I use a condom it popped
and then when you get a Saddam's partner
for your corners pop fam you don't do it
the right way they told you in school
you got pinched the top for a minute
I'm [ __ ] gay on bro they don't want to
smash get a [ __ ] when I ain't got time
to pinch anything I just rolled it on
front anyway
saying I'd cover one sorry first time
you use the condom it popped first time
he's kind of approach whereas sir so now
now us and I say to her now that
recently I've been using condoms I've
been being good but the euphoria of raw
sex you can't compare it to anything in
this world anything in this world like
the moment in time nothing else matters
skin to skin is a different thing skin
ready text read out to skin is a
different thing oh my day
condoms are so boring they are you know
he's I went I'm not ready to say I went
years without using a condom yeah oh so
but say mine was more of a psychological
thing yeah
because how was it like when I lost my
virginity what was I when I lost my
virginity like I think I was 17 I think
I was 16 when I 17 got it how do I
explain it I think I was 16 when I got
it in the 17 when I actually had sex
with someone like I did okay right so
explain what this almost ties in with
the the psychological condom thing so
basically I was seeing a girl when I was
about 16 yeah she'd had like she'd been
out here [ __ ] so her ex before was
like some guy in his 20s or whatever and
obviously she'd just been out here
[ __ ] yeah I'd never [ __ ] but
obviously you don't tell them that you
just like yeah him as a bad I know I do
I do yeah and so I was nervous in it of
course so time and time and time and
time again I'll go around our house
we're doing the normal teenage [ __ ] with
kissing and fingering bashing all that
stuff yeah and then she what was it she
starts initiating like um I'm trying to
[ __ ] kind of thing and I'm feeling out
the [ __ ] and I'm like obviously I'm
trying to [ __ ] as well yes heart beating
yeah
and I'm like hey I'm trying to [ __ ]
she's ah he got a condom stuff and I'm
like nah
and then like she was like okay cool
well obviously I'm not on anything so
let's just leave it for now if you
haven't got a condom and in my head as
annoying as it was I was relieved yeah I
was relieved I was like thank [ __ ] I
dodged that bullet boy cuz yeah I'm like
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
brother yeah I'm definitely gonna bus in
about four seconds never had sex before
I've just been at a wanking two point
since I was about 13 I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm gonna do I don't know what
it's gonna be like and then like the
only thing I was confident was was I
reckon my I reckon my dick is big enough
to do the thing mmm but I don't know
like I don't know if I'm gonna perform
kind of that's what my my worry was and
I was just like I thank God I didn't
have that condom yeah then I had to get
the condom because next time she knows
we're [ __ ] yeah so basically get the
condom as a teenager I must support like
a whole box and that night I'm like let
me just practice putting in one let me
practice putting in one so in a million
women the moment go smooth I'm not
fiddling about from smart I'm not
fiddling about I you know I've never but
I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it
and I'm like alright cool man I think
I've got it down so we go over there get
into it normal normal clothes are coming
off and as we're getting closer to it
closer to I'm thinking okay I need to
pull out the condom and then like the
gun were going my heart's beating rough
and then I can she goes I forgot the
condom and I'm like yeah yeah yeah I'm
going to my wallet pull out the condom
I'm like I'm trying to do the thing that
I practice in my head and then like when
to do it and it was inside out yeah yeah
yeah yeah bro halfway down in the mouth
and now I'm sweating
now I'm [ __ ] suede and I'm not
[ __ ] like this is not why I practice
it's not going like the [ __ ] audition
[Laughter]
this is why we do dress rehearsals [ __ ]
so I flipped it around didn't sing try
and get on on my [ __ ] and now cuz I'm so
panicked and nervous I'm losing my
hard-on and I'm like no no no so like I
literally just fought like let me just
get it in there yeah and then I'll
probably get hard again yeah finally got
the condom on I'm I'm um I'm down to
like a semi job right now and I'm like
typical let me squeeze the it's the end
of it yeah and then just want to get it
in the fire yeah
so I basically got it in lost all of it
breath lost all of it I just psyched
myself out and then literally from then
anytime a condom was mentioned but
literally the next they sound 16 then
three years panic mode broke my palms
will get sway I would have [ __ ] ghost
give me a condom that was too small and
it was just not fitting they'll tear and
I stuff like that and I'm just like
panic buff so yeah but from the age of
16 to like 19 raw raw everything bra she
enjoyed it I enjoyed it Oh Ross risque
yeah and there was [ __ ] problems to
be had because of it but boy I couldn't
do what Conor's feet yes nothing
compares to raw sex yes my boy was not
happy cuz yeah you're right nothing not
flee when I did have sick the first time
I had actual sex with the condom
couldn't even come you can even go I was
drunk as well and even common I was like
this is a waste of time and then I found
out girls hate condoms and I was like
you know we're both adults
I'll just pull out I'll be fine in it
never fight it's never fun once you get
those that always that seventh time
you're comfortable and don't pull out
you become deep missionary missions you
know them once we have to pull out a
little bit because it's too deep so you
pull out a little bit then you just
release that final love oral sex then
and then like you have every intention
of pulling out everything you want to
give it to the last element and then
that first little bit comes out and it's
a wrap and it's a rat [ __ ] mom I
might as well village kick cuz they
ended today isn't it ruff aah roars that
is the only way to go [ __ ] man bareback
boy bareback is blackjack the only game
to play oh I love raw sex same key same
like I said have been good recently it
had a very good reason to yeah so I'm
trying to keep on form and stay on form
but you know you [ __ ] mmm both speaking
of my teenage experiences have you have
you seen big mouth good the new think
I'm a like Episode three or four or
something I'm not having finished it
every time I watch big mouth yeah it
resonates rough and I was thinking
actually was that work the other day and
I thought we need to talk about this on
the podcast anyway I don't think any
well obviously every guy knows I don't
think any female understands what it's
like being a teenage boy grubbing up
going few PB in terms of how poorly you
get right here it's [ __ ] terrified is
where your [ __ ] yeah any any things we
think about sex 24/7 bro
anything anything perfect example me
when I was in school we must have been
that 14 13 14 and I found out all my
whole group of friends found out that
two of my boys would get in haha say the
story read because if anyone from my
school I don't think anyone for my
school's watching this anyway way they
do their know who I'm talking about
yeah to another girl that one of the
guys to the boys
yeah we're routinely getting sucked off
in the science cupboard by one fresh
African go of one eye one eye one eye
what the [ __ ]
brother they were horny they didn't give
a [ __ ] she was down to do it said they
were down to get what the fit was grim
what the [ __ ] brother horny and not
to me always pots um whenever I think of
being a like an undeniably horny
teenager yeah that story was pops in my
head and it makes me laugh because I
think you would I would have done the
same because I remember when I found out
yes lucky con yeah
you ever get lucky prick lucky pricks
getting sucked off in the science of a
brother long opportunists that's what
yeah and then um
oh brother being a horny teenage boy is
scary
mm scare I'm them random boners you get
in class and they tell you to stand up
when you get random Bona is a fear of
mine a fear of mine girls Fink you got
it bad like if you're horny it doesn't
show maybe your nipples get tender who
gives a [ __ ] no I mean who gives a
flying [ __ ] you can't see you're horny
but guy gets funny in public especially
be wearing like tight jeans or trousers
or anything or short shorts wrap by
roused to get money from anything
anything the girl was like if I go if
it's hot outside and then one of the
girls decided just coming in like a
skirt but if I saw any bit of new cast
less makeup and above anything from the
patella up let's rap I'm not sleeping
tonight engine tower morning it was
literally the worst tina matter girls i
would have [ __ ] when I was a teenager
is horrific
if they were down if they were down and
they told me I'm down brother could have
been six foot eight morbidly obese smell
like [ __ ] I didn't give a [ __ ] I didn't
give a [ __ ] I think we're gonna have to
teach my son this as well because he's
gonna be wired brother yeah I don't have
to let him know like son it's alright
it's not true I know how old you ice
alright happens bro yeah man just get at
some trampy girl at school to wank you
off and you'll feel so much better you
feel so much bad you're mine who just be
clear up cuz boy my mind was clouded
like the girls get horny as they can't
they'd literally calm then or during
puberty baby now yes who knows but
during PB i dont think its paw someone
goes there's only as guys one else no
please
because yeah someone
someone listen to this and message me
and tell me because it's worrying bro
it's actually scary you know it is this
so [ __ ] scary is it is it is like
said hard dicks make you eat like that's
why you've got a [ __ ] rapist all that
hard dick makes you do crazy things
crazy things crazy things
this is disgustingly controversial but
it's a fact it reminds me when you're
watching the video earlier you'll know
when I say is it the my man I can't
breathe you're right side bro the the
Lich like the epitome of hard dick makes
you do stupid things pedophile CFR 0p
defiles breath and it sounds it's
controversial yeah it sounds disgusting
to even broach as a topic yeah but
pedophiles know they're go in jail
forever
yeah and they're going to prison forever
IRAs F but they're willing to risk it
that's wild they're willing to risk it
they were in to risk it all that's wild
that's one that's wild for routine and
they know it's wrong
and they're like she's like all he she
or he is like seven I'm game
I know it's disgusting I know I'm sick I
know I'm wrong and I know I'm going to
[ __ ] jail if I get caught but boy
hard thing we should do crazy things man
man it's [ __ ] disgraceful it's
disgraceful but yeah boy that's that's
that's all there is
candy nine about that it's almost been a
pillar out you imagine a pedophile
having a growth hormone next I'm telling
if I can do it [ __ ] go [ __ ] do it
from big mouth that's disgusting that's
disgusting it's not funny it's not funny
at all it's not funny at all it's not
funny it's all fat that's bad that's Fox
what's my man's name more like Maury as
I remember
ah they go on [ __ ] hormone monster
tell you've not watch big mouth if
you're not watch big mouth [ __ ] watch
it [ __ ] hilarious oh my god
you took that too far it's so funny but
it's much because the thing is like
that's such a great show because at that
stage in our lives we're all thinking
about sex but we don't know what to do
work resonates and it's all fear is in a
cartoon whole thing resin-based vulgar
base true like because that's the way we
thought back when we were kids girls
didn't know what to do guys in know what
to do we had horny guys got horny girls
but that's their subconscious telling
them so I would do what I don't do it
bro and it's Matt he was crazy I
remember the first do you remember the
first ever wank you had oh no God no God
no I do
god no I how I was I couldn't take it
anymore yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but I
couldn't physically take it my hormones
were going not right they were doing
backflips no it's just I remember I was
on a family holiday oh my god then we
will walk in this is Armin but we're in
Spain or somewhere walking down the
beach and there was just too much I was
walking down the beach and deck and
there's a woman sunbathing and prov she
must have been like 60 she was old and
gross but she had a tease out and I was
just like from game I am gay she's got
these old nasty teeth and I'm beyond the
game yeah I need like rock I couldn't
take it yeah and I must've been like 13
14 and I can't take it anymore
like something's gotta give yeah and
then I remember I got home that night
someone was I was in my room and then I
was literally just like I can't remember
I haven't taught myself that James we
can't live like this but we can't live
like this bro we were fantasizing over
nasty six-year-old women yeah that
common broth and then
I remember thinking like I was with his
banking business about what is
masturbation business let me have a
piece of that if you ever be sad cuz
something's gotta give and then I
remember I'll go for it and I was like
and then I remember like I was close my
eyes imagining I was imagining like the
hottest thing I could think of and I was
just like yeah that's working we're
working and then the rest is history
that's probably why you can wank without
without with my head yeah yeah you watch
porn from early from young January young
really can't wank without porn like
everyone close my eyes think of stuff
and Wonka busts those like good best
ones I guess where you're coming from in
terms of the imagination blah blah
especially if you're thinking about
something that actually happened I know
I need to see it I mean I need to see it
I can't I just can't get hard from a lot
of ii get hard from thoughts but I can't
bus are not from thoughts I visually see
the imagination masturbation's are
masturbation they're the one I remember
Tyler fat for the speaking of horn
speaking of porn so funny I remember
when I got into porn I was in deep of
the teenager horny wherefore in deep and
I remember I got home from school one
day yet I didn't have a laptop I didn't
have a phone I didn't have nothing what
we had was the looking family PC yeah
yeah and then I got from school and I'm
like let me just bash one out quickly
yeah got home I'm like yeah yeah yeah
yeah bash one out I went to sort myself
out and I've completely forgot it was
just on the screen
my [ __ ] brother came home with his
friend oh I dunno what my man said the
worst bit by it he didn't even defend me
he was even in my corner he didn't even
like trying to like distract his friend
yeah yeah yeah my man walked in well I'm
sitting watching TV so I'm saying watch
TV here the PCs like here and it just on
you completely forgot about lately
forgot fam I told you once you bus you
don't think you just you're done and
that's it I literally left it there and
it was the Screamers
watching TV my brother walks in he's
like James not again James not good like
what Rob and I was like no and I'm like
ya know what is that mom one of my boys
told me about this this weird thing
without this horse was doing the thing
with his woman and I was needed here
because I thought it was interesting
he's our boy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] ever man
said not again and that was the peak
thing because I was thinking how many
times how many times this happened
that's funny
bro it was horrifying I remember the
first day I got clocked watching porn
how am i dad I was scared for my life
scared for my life say you know you know
one sky this was I was living in Crystal
Palace so this would have been over 15
years ago probably I was a kid
hmm probably between like I don't even
know how when I was a kid so you know
one on Sky two got there like red-hot
channels I'm at nine nine whatever in
like nine 19 same station I remembered
the one I was watching specifically
because he asked my sister first but the
reason why I asked my sister if it was
her was because I was watching like red
hot girls on girls that's what I was
watching
no that's why it got left on yeah I mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but if it I
don't remember I won't or not whatever
yeah but I left the onion I went to bed
I went to school came home the next day
my dad was like I think my dad asked my
sister separately who were you were you
watching this or was this was it for you
MA
and she was like nah of course not and
he asked me but I don't if I lied or
told you I can't remember all I know is
that he beat my ass he [ __ ] beat me
that's that's literally what I remember
like he took me to the garden he took me
to the garden and beat the [ __ ] on me
beat I was a kid brother watching porn
porn yeah I know I know is that's hard
anyways he was doing the right finger
I'm not 18 did I read as a parent he did
the right thing
my dad did the complete opposite when he
clocked me boy Eddie's pudgy first of
all 98 spot me he he found it the way
unneeded him to Furman first of all
that's been told me you told me first
thing anyway the same thing happened
that happened to you happened to me but
my dad didn't say [ __ ] yeah he just
turned the TV on my brother was there he
was on that the only reason I know my
dad [ __ ] because my brother told me so
yeah there was that one yeah and then
there was an actual time when I was
literally bashing literally my dad of Z
is his house you don't knock yeah if he
wants to come in my room he just call me
in the [ __ ] room yeah yeah so I'm
just watching saying bashing off and he
just comes in and he's like opens the
door and he's like yeah James so in and
he closed the door and he left it about
nine tenths of a second and then open
back and just finish the sentence he's
gave me just enough time to sort my [ __ ]
out and let me walk back in he was like
yes sir James oh yeah so what is and I
was like yeah yeah fully watching a
movie like molesting myself I've never
been so embarrassed in my [ __ ] life
bro some way you starkers on top of your
bedsheets
No so how it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't
it was a learning way I've never had it
first of all I don't know what you do
Bob I've never had a wank naked in my
life who bus is a quick not completely
naked oh my god what you doing oh my god
no I just literally oh my god just have
like my trousers yeah here innit
yeah and I'm cool disgusting teenager
like arch back I'm just
I'm hot that was funny that was funny
yeah yeah so like I just had a little
sign out so all I had to do was just
tuck my chin and then God talked to me
like it was no money left and I've never
been so grateful for that because if my
dad yeah yeah yeah it would if you
poured you up on it yeah if you pour me
up on it I'd be more more in your
situation I'd be more mortified the fact
that I got clocked yeah
than the beating yeah I can take the be
embarrassed man yeah clot me he's just I
can't handle it I can't handle that bro
that's too much that's [ __ ] that's funny
there's way too much oh my god random if
you had one power what would it be
power hmm anything no what would it be
jesus what a [ __ ] knob of I always
used to say it was like super speed a
sign louder sound something typical like
the flash was fine but now that I think
about it probably something a little bit
more practical mm-hmm brought to be fair
you ever seen the film what women want
with Mel Gibson reading minds yes we
could read women's minds and you can
select whose mind you want to read yes
exactly exactly what I would say right
that's what I mean able to read minds
that's why I need that is only thing I
need I was so happy that power is
literally the best thing in the world
the best thing in the world there's
nothing else more you need to do in life
as long as you can read a woman's mind
or read a mind or select the person's
mind you want to read it's a wrap we're
good why you've won everything we're
good you've won everything we're good
that's all there is I'm glad you said
that because that's exactly was thinking
about yeah man I was thinking about that
typical super cows but boy for since the
day I saw that film I was like he was
things as well walk him through the road
I remember I just looking at this thing
I see using a name look yeah I remember
I remember that ah that's because as
soon as like she's just like you walk
past her she's alright mmm you're in
you're in ha your reign you've got the
confidence to just say or do what you
want and it's like we're good it's
they're not knowing the hurts probe hmm
then again I don't think I could handle
hearing every [ __ ] thing like yuck yeah
but that's the way you got selective oh
yeah I don't you mean yeah yeah cuz I
don't know
they're thinking before I select a
minute yeah so I select the monopolies a
bit all right
and she looks at me she's like yeah but
yeah man anyway Oh want to wrap it up
yeah ma'am before we wrap it up has a
girl ever ate yours before
no god no I'm not saying it because the
girls ate my it's just a topic that I've
written down I was like we need to talk
about no one's ever ate Mars what why
was it a topic what because it baffles
me why girls do it I think I approached
it before Cartman before happen I think
we did because I said I remember I was
doing the editing and I remember hearing
it I think I said you said something or
something like we'll talk about g-spot
mmm I need my g-spot like I need my
appendix or my tonsils or something like
that right any math alone and the thing
is this is the thing that is actually to
be discussed yeah
and we're talking about we spoke about
it before but getting your are say is
just gay it's just gay there's no
position you can be in that's not gay
cuz it's all about a position it's not
the actor it's not the fact that your
ass is getting a yes affect the of the
contortion you have to put yourself here
to get your arse a so you either doing
one of two things you're laying back and
you're spreading in there get your
cheeks gay or you're on walls and you're
arching your back gay getting off I was
getting you a ski in his game also us
I've seen it on Twitter or I think it's
most definitely Twitter it was a snippet
of some girls in America talking about
if a guy gets one girl was adamant that
if a guy gets penetrated by a girl like
using a dildo whatever he's not gay
but then no three girls are saying he's
not gay but one guy was Adam and he's
[ __ ] gay big man you are [ __ ] gay
you're gay you're gay
Oh getting penetrated your game there's
no reason on this earth way she'd get
penetrated you get as a man unless you
are gay I haven't no I'm not homophobic
like I I work with so many gay people
I've met something gave you my life and
they don't bother being gay but it's
nothing okay why if you get if you're
straight man and you enjoy getting
penetrated
if you joy exploring that you are gay
because there's no diff there is no
difference between that and a dick there
was no different no brother I remember I
told you this years ago when I was
talking to that go and she was seeing a
guy and she was saying I remember I
remember he said his exact words were
I'm not gay but if a girl had a dick I'd
wanted to [ __ ] me go home boy you're gay
what if my Joe had a dick so basically
if you kill my channel was a man I'd
want her to [ __ ] me so yeah if you were
fun the training that's basically cool
okay Rob it's oh it's all right but you
get it wrong we'll be in gaming again
that's wild fun mm-hmm why optic that
you just bought oh yeah yeah that's it
that's it that's it because I remember
you want to do it would you rather and I
thought of a really funny would you
rather I hear you don't necessarily a
funny one is not even that disgusting
but makes me think would you rather yeah
speaking is pulls back to the once like
once you finish coming you're just done
would you rather get held down this is
for 30 seconds each held down and get
[ __ ] tickled o'hagan tickle held the
[ __ ] you they said is it you skin
savagely tickler like a die or held down
you've just come and a go sucks you off
so a girl sucks you off until you come
and she keeps [ __ ] seconds before
before answer yeah
girls we don't like I'm spirit I've just
come stop sucking me off they know as
well cuz after they just come if I keep
you ever to kept going after yeah
yeah exactly that yeah or that shaggy
exactly that don't do it to me bro
which one held down a tickled or sucked
off after you just come say a sec this
is a long time I'm held down boy if I
can't move company for either I think I
would have to firm the cane stalks off
while I overcome I can't I can't
I am so ticklish I am so ticklish is
unreal unreal I think I'll be able to
firm it more than getting too cold
because game good I'd want to [ __ ]
hit someone I'll break the chains of
[ __ ] hit someone [ __ ] hate getting
tickled
I'm sorry it's the worst oh my god it's
the worst what about you old you jeez
no bro because getting sucked off after
I've just come is the worst I think I
might actually take the sucked off one
I'd have to because after like yeah yeah
yeah I think I'd have to get sucked off
actually no no no I might actually get
tickled really uh because then again you
know why because the sucked off one hmm
I've always been able I've never had to
bear it for more than like a second yeah
cuz I'm always just says stop stop stop
stop stop and it's over we're
particularly never had to bear it before
and it's torture which is probably why
I've got such a thing in my head like I
can't handle it but then I'm thinking of
that one second one I'm like you need to
stop for the suck in that for 30 seconds
I die I would die I host him I'll pull
my eyes on because your [ __ ] it's dry I
don't know I think I'd firm I'd firm
getting hurt
off the bus on or not I think I'd phone
getting tickled I'm cutting article but
the person that is some unbearable is
it's painful because my my tall is to
sent my helmet is too sensitive I don't
need any of that anymore I just need to
Kip is [ __ ] true you're so painful oh
right let me wrap this up man that's
good have a couple drinks and have a
good time all right be will tune in
again tomorrow